TV's $20,000,000 woman Ellen Pompeo has
a new love and tris on Grey's Anatomy
I'm here for it I am all-in but can
anyone actually live up to Meredith and
McDreamy it seems How I Met Your
mother's Josh Radnor sure gonna try it's
wrong with you look weird oh my god you
have a date Josh is Meredith's blind
lunch date in tonight's episode
but reaction to the 44 year old as
grey's new guy has been mixed fan tweets
include McMurphy and hasn't Meredith
suffered enough we can't tell anyone
about this deal deal deal
any guy who comes after McDreamy will
definitely have a tough time winning
over fans mares men so far
well she recently had a sex fantasy with
De Luca and new ortho godly know that a
deal-breaker there was that rebound
romance with Riggs but the show's big
missed opportunity was a legit
relationship with surgeon turned patient
Scott Speedman never have to see me
again
oh and way before that remember make
that Chris O'Donnell you get any sleep
last night
not really graze has a pretty high
standard when it comes to casting men
and one fan raised this question if
Meredith does not get a hot love
interest does this signal the end of
grace I've been saying for the record
that the show is gonna end since season
two that's right how will you and Shonda
like know when it's time to actually
close this chapter close this plot I
think the fans will let us know really
yeah yeah when people aren't as
passionate about it it's time to call it
um let me just say Ellen Pompeo is
Grey's Anatomy no love interest to make
the show better yeah great as it is yes
it is
[Music]